could have been stopped in China before
it started and it wasn't and the whole
world is suffering because of it if they
were knowingly responsible certainly if
they did if it was a mistake a mistake
is a mistake but if they were knowingly
responsible yeah then there should be
consequences
president Trump suggests China could
face consequences over the origins of
Kovan 19 if they were knowingly
responsible as a representative from the
Wuhan lab speaking publicly for the
first time telling a Chinese state
broadcaster as we said early on there's
no way this virus came from us we have a
strict regulatory regime and a code of
conduct of research so we are confident
of that but our next guest says now is
not the time to forget the true nature
of the Chinese regime Jim Hansen is
president of the security studies group
and he served in the US Army Special
Forces Jim thanks for being with us this
morning they say no chance it could have
come from them well it almost certainly
did and the question of whether it came
from the uhat Wuhan lab or whether it
came from another source they covered it
up once it started and that's the true
crime against humanity they knew it was
happening they knew it was human to
human transmittable and they hid it from
the world they disappeared the evidence
they disappeared the doctors and they
took away our chance to potentially stop
this from becoming a global pandemic
they need to pay for that
what should the president do to make
them pay because we know the evil nature
of this regime and they can't be trusted
and we can't disentangle ourselves from
China as easily as we'd like to but
secretary minuchin said a good thing he
should be helping all US countries that
do work in China that manufacture there
to come back to the United States and
this is a perfect art of the deal moment
for President Trump he's got all the
leverage because the world knows that
this is China's problem he should use
that to make some massively good for us
trade deals with the Chinese
Jim put us inside the head of the
Chinese Communist Party what's the play
behind covering up disappearing
scientists delaying letting the world
know denying on the back end even all
that
is against you what are the communists
trying to do avoid blame you know the
nice thing about an authoritarian regime
is you can do things like make a city
disappear they more or less disappeared
Wuhan for a while they shut it down
they ran people away and and what they
did was use their authoritarian
totalitarian powers to shut down media
shut down any ability to report and they
tried to hide it hoping it would go away
unfortunately for the world it didn't
and now it's time to hold them and the
global organizations like the w-h-o that
help them that colluded to hide that
from the world held them accountable in
some sort of either tribunal or let's
fire the whole leadership of the w-h-o
and start over absolutely and I could
not agree more now is precisely the time
to bring all that manufacturing all that
business home here and follow the ABCs
anywhere but China Jim Hansen thank you
very much for your insight and your
service we appreciate it good to be with
you Pete got it